كل هذه النجاحات تحولت لتحديات امام روسيا
رغم انها اعدت العده قبل ذلك وبسنوات عام
2008 ورغم نجاح العمليه الروسيه في جورجيا
عمليا وجهت انتقادات كبيره لجهاز
الاستخبارات بوتا اعتبرها فرصه لفرض
الاصلاح وعين ايجور كوب مديرا للاستخبارات
العسكريه ولا يزال محتفظا بمنصبه حتى
الانبا اسس شبكه عملاء متعدده في اوكرانيا
وبدلا بدا الاستعداد للحرب الحرب الحاليه
صيفه عام 2021 الا انه طلب من بوتين تاجيل
العمليه من اجل ضمان نجاحها
وتنرفض التاجيل ووافق على ذلك كان يعدل
تقاريره بما يرضي سيد الكريميون وربما
يكون ذلك سبب احتفاظه بمصيبه حتى الان لكن
بعض التقارير الخاطئه حول استقبال الروس
بالورود وهروب القياده الاوكرانيه كان لها
وقع كارثي وذلك اضافه لتدمير اوكرانيا
بمساعده الغرب لشبكه العملاء في اوكرانيا
ضربه قويه لكن روسيا لم تقل كلمتها
الاخيره معلومات الناتو كانت مكشوفه
لروسيا ايضا منذ البدايه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات